all right liz
liz where are you from originally
i'm from new jersey
glenn ridge it's a
small
suburban town not far from
new york city tell me about your family
um
yeah i had
i had a good childhood my
um
my my mom
had kind of a high up job in
the city so
she commuted every day and she worked
long hours so
i didn't
she wasn't around a lot but my dad was
the one who
he worked from home and
he was the one really taking care of me
and my brother as far as like getting us
ready for school and meals and
all that
sounds like a good childhood
it was good yeah
um
when i was
i was around
six
or five or six my parents
they wanted to
have another
child
and
they
tried
everything under the sun and they
couldn't conceive so
they decided to
adopt
and they
decided to adopt a baby from mexico
so when i was
six
my parents and i
uh went to tijuana mexico
and
my my brother was he was a newborn
um
when we adopted him and
so
the first month
we were there we were all there together
living in tijuana for a month and then
after a month
my mom had to get back to her job i had
to get back to school
so
my mom and i left and my dad stayed and
then for like a month or two after that
my mom and i kind of were a little back
and forth between here and
tijuana
and
so
after
after like
two
i want to say almost two months
everything kind of fell apart
as far as the adoption
the lawyer that
my parents were using
was basically a crook and he
was providing
um fraudulent birth certificates
and he was doing it to a lot of people
and stealing their money
uh
so he and he was under investigation at
the time and
my
parents
so they had to get a new lawyer
and
my
the the adoption was basically null and
void and my
parents could not take my brother back
to the u.s legally
and my
dad was also told that he could be
arrested at any point
and that my brother could be taken away
from them at any point
so they got a new lawyer and
she told them
on the birth certificate it they were
told that
my brother's birth mother was a school
teacher
um and it she had a fake name it wasn't
a real person
and
so
the first thing that they had to do was
find my brother's actual birth mom
and they had to have her full
cooperation in order to move ahead with
the adoption and take my brother home
so
it was
yeah so
um
my
my parents
found
the uh his birth mom
and she was
a sex worker
and my mom actually went they found out
where she lived and my mom actually went
to her apartment
and um
[Music]
apparently there were needles everywhere
and drug paraphernalia so we don't we're
not 100 certain that his birth mom was
using drugs when she was pregnant with
him but all signs kind of point to that
um but they found her and she cooperated
and
10 months later
um
my dad was in tijuana for 10 months
dealing with this my mom and
myself were back home waiting for him
and 10 months later
it finally went through and he was able
to bring my brother home
so
it was
really
devastating
for my parents both financially
emotionally
um
it was difficult for me
being a little girl and i was so used to
having my dad around all the time and
then he was just gone all of a sudden
for almost a year
and now of course looking back i'm like
he didn't really have
a choice you know he couldn't leave but
at the time i didn't
of course i didn't understand it but uh
yeah so eventually you got a brother
i was very excited yeah
and how was
life with your new brother
uh it was fun i i remember yeah i was
um so excited to have a sibling and have
a little brother
um
yeah like we had
we had fun together
growing up
it wasn't until
he's i should say he's well yeah he's he
was 24 when he died but uh
uh it wasn't until
high school
that
he started having
trouble
in school and started getting into
alcohol and drugs before we go into that
let me just back up a bit yeah so i mean
like growing up with your with your
brother it was
pretty much
how would you compare to having a
biological brother
uh
felt the same you said me he was your he
was your brother yes absolutely yeah he
became part of the family yeah
yeah
and then when did you first see signs of
of trouble
yeah probably
when i would say
when he started
high school he
um
he was always kind of going against like
societal norms
in the way that he acted the way that he
dressed the music he listened to like he
was
he took everything to
the extreme um
and
he
like he just liked to look different and
be different
and i think
the town we grew up in was
predominantly white and him having
darker skin and being from mexico and
adopted i think
had an effect on him as well i don't
think he ever
felt like he fit in
and is there any any drug use any
history of that in your family at all
you your parents
no uh
i mean
my
my dad's side has some like alcoholism
but
that's about it
so it's not something you guys are used
to
no
no
uh
yeah it was
it was difficult
i
was your brother's name max max yeah
yeah so
i felt like
i think we had a really special
relationship where
he
confided in me a lot and he really
trusted me with certain things and i
know that he
would tell me things that he wouldn't
necessarily tell my parents or other
people
so
there were things that i saw
um as far as like
him using drugs
um
in the house for example but i never
told anyone i didn't tell my parents
because
i didn't want to break that trust i
wanted him to still be able to come to
me and
i wanted to be like a good sister
so it
was was difficult
do you wish now that you had said
something
to your parents perhaps
yes but also
i'm not sure because i don't
think
it would have made it any type of
difference
um
yeah there's a lot of things that
looking back
i wonder
should i have done this should i have
said this i could have done this but at
the end of the day
um
i know now like i'm at peace with
the fact that there's absolutely nothing
i could have done to change the outcome
of what happened
what drugs was using
in high school oh like anything that he
could get his hands on
he was a big drinker
um
yeah
really really anything like
when i say he he was extreme in anything
that he did he would do any drug that
was handed to him and do like all of it
like he was just
uh
but it it wasn't until
i want to say
after
well his drug use was
bad towards the end of high school and
then he
managed to graduate high school
and
he
i don't know when he got into heroin
i really i don't know when he started
using i don't know if it was high school
or after high school but
after high school he got
pretty bad into heroin and
my he was
in and out of rehabs and my parents were
doing everything that they could and he
would go to rehab and then
you know relapse
so
he
and my parents
basically they kicked him out they
didn't they you know
i assume up until here
up until this point he had the same
childhood you did
yeah same loving parents oh yeah yeah
yeah
so it looks like a genetic yeah i think
so
thing yeah
yeah very loving parents who did
absolutely i mean
they loved both of us so much and
did everything that they could and but
it's like
again
it's so hard to know what to do
um when you have a loved one that's
suffering from addiction
um
but
he
he won i mean he was deep in his
addiction and he
moved out and he was
homeless for a while he was living
in new york uh
living on the streets
so it was
it was really scary for
my parents and for me
i mean it was constant
worry about him
where he was what he was doing
is he
gonna die today is he gonna end up in
jail like
really anything could happen at any
moment and
and so
i
made the decision that
at the time that i um
i couldn't have him in my life if
he was
not going to get help
um because it was just too difficult for
me and it was too difficult seeing my
parents and i was very angry at him
so
me and him didn't talk for
probably three to four years
and
yeah
and it was still like regardless
even not speaking to him i was still
constantly worried about him
um but
it was too difficult to
to communicate with him a lot of the
time
uh
so
yeah we hadn't
um
spoken for
yeah a few years and
i
and i knew he was living in new york
city but then he
went out to la to go to rehab
and
i still hadn't talked to him yet but i
got a call one day from
a woman who worked at this rehab and she
said hey
you know you're max's sister
we
have a
family weekend coming up here in la and
i was living in new jersey at the time
um and max
would love it if you came he said he
really wants you there
and
so i went
i went to see him and it was the first
time that i saw him in
a few years and he was it was the first
time i saw him sober in a few years or
in more than a few years in a long time
um
and
that was
hands down the best weekend of my life
spending that weekend with my my brother
and he was so happy i was there and he
was so proud and like telling everyone
like oh it's my sister like she came all
the way from new jersey you know and he
was so happy i was there and and
um i was so happy to see him sober but
it was always
you know he had been in that place
before like as far as being in rehab and
being sober so i was never too hopeful
about it
um i was like very cautiously hopeful
every time he
got sober
but
that was
yeah it was that was a really beautiful
weekend that i spent with him
um how old was he been he was
so that was about a year before he died
so he was 23.
[Music]
yeah
um
and so i felt like
seeing him that weekend i felt it felt
really good because it felt like we were
kind of
we were like
establishing this new relationship
um
and
i was really excited uh for it
uh
i felt the most hopeful that weekend
that i felt in a long time
um
so
after that i
i didn't see him i
i didn't see him at all we talked we
we texted a lot we talked on the phone
um
he sounded like he was doing really well
you know made a lot of friends and
uh
also i
should say when i was at this family
weekend at his rehab we had a a therapy
session uh it was just the two of us and
and the therapist there and
and he
he apologized to me he said
he called me sis and he said sis i'm so
sorry for
what i put you through growing up
and it was the first time he ever like
acknowledged
acknowledged it or like any of the
hurt that he caused
and and i knew it was really genuine and
i think i i just felt really close to
him in that moment
but so he yeah he was living in la and
he really he loved it there and he
really like
made that his home and
um
i was still living in new jersey
and then
my mom this was about a month before he
died my mom and i went out to visit him
in
la
and
i
he didn't say that he
had been using but i just
because i
just had been through it so often
before with him i just had a feeling
like he was just acting
i don't know
different and he wasn't acting like the
way that i that he was when i saw him
before that
so
that was a really hard visit and i just
left with kind of like a bad feeling
i can't really explain it
and then
a month later
i was actually
i was at work and
it was
march
march 21st of 2017
and
i got a call from my mom
and she said max overdosed
your dad's in la right now with him at
the hospital
[Music]
and
yeah and so i went home and and i just
like
i don't know it's all kind of a blur
um
but i knew it wasn't good
and
um
i don't even remember like how i slept
that night but i did
and then
the following day
my mom and i
took a plane out to l.a
and he
we went directly to the hospital
and there were some friends
of his that were there and and
you know we
walked into his room my dad was there
and
my brother was
on life support
and
uh
and that was on
wednesday or
wednesday night
um
and then
the next day
it's like
all of his friends were there that he
had met in la and that was really
special they were all um
friends that he had met who were in
recovery
so they were all by his side and
i remember
the doctor they they did some brain
scans on him and the doctor coming in
and
reading us and we were all surrounding
my brother and he was in this bed
and
he read us the
results
and
he said i forget how long my
brother was
without
oxygen to his brain but because it had
been so long that
um he was basically
brain dead and in this he would be in
this vegetative state forever and would
probably never be able to breathe on his
own again
and like um
that that's when it really hit me
because and i remember the doctor
saying that and i just like my my legs
like gave out like i just
um
because i knew that like he was gone
and uh
and i just remember crying
and
[Music]
holding my mom
um
[Music]
and uh
yeah we just stayed by his side
all day that day and then
my parents i mean we made the decision
to
take him off life support later that
night
so
i think it was a thursday around like 8
30
at night he was taken off life support
and he
didn't
actually die until
friday at 10 30 in the morning so we
were just up all night
with him
and
just like waiting for him to
like
pass
um
i felt like i was
in this like dream
state and i was so tired we were all so
tired from not sleeping or eating and
just
um
it's like i could still hear like the
the sound of like the ventilator and the
beeping it just
and
and then he died on friday
and
and i just
remember
just holding his hand
i don't know there's like nothing that
can prepare you like i i thought i would
i always
i felt like before he died i was almost
i had to kind of prepare myself for that
because i knew it was such a strong
possibility
but nothing could prepare you for like
actually happening and
seeing
someone you love
like
just
in a hospital bed um
and uh
yeah it was
it was
really traumatic for all of us
do you feel there was anything you could
have done
no
i think that if he
if he hadn't died that day if he hadn't
overdosed
when he did it would have happened at
some point
i know that i i don't i don't know that
he ever would have
gotten sober and stayed sober
unfortunately
um
i also think a part of him like really
liked that lifestyle of
living on the streets and
[Music]
i don't know i
i mean
he
i think he felt
in a way like most
at home
there
like more at home than he did at his
actual home with us on the streets
yeah
yeah i've seen that a lot yeah
he had a it was like his family and
yeah they just don't feel comfortable
with a better situation a better living
situation
exactly
and
yeah i i think i mean i know he he was
also he struggled with depression and
there was a you know mental illness too
yeah
he was
i know he was suffering a lot
i don't think he really
cared
whether he lived or died like i don't
think he would have ever like
tried to kill himself but
i
i just don't think he really cared
towards the end
either way
do you feel like this is just the way he
was
he was just born this way genetically it
was inside him from birth i do
and i think
i think it was
mostly
genetic because again we were raised the
same way with the same loving parents
but
i think
him being adopted played a huge part in
it
he had that
feeling of
you know not being wanted or abandoned
from very early on and i don't think he
ever really like
came to terms with that i guess and i
think he
just never felt like he fit in and he
felt
very lonely
and sad
a lot of the time
do you feel like there's anything you've
learned from all of this
i think i've learned a lot
i've learned i i think
when i was going through this with him
um i had a lot of anger i still do i
still
um the therapy has helped a lot but
i was very angry at him
and
and i
and i don't think i really understood
addiction the way i do now
and
now
i've
i feel like i
have so much more
love and compassion for
people who are suffering with addiction
and i've learned that
people who use drugs people who are
addicted to drugs
or
put a needle in their arm whatever
whatever it is
deserve just as much love and compassion
as
anyone else
because i see my brother and
all addicts now
um
you feel like it's a mental
illness more than a
predisposition to drug addiction
uh
to me i see the mindset
that they have yeah
opens the door for drug use yeah which
always leads to an addiction right
yeah i think it maybe it's a
mix of both yeah yeah
i've also learned that
um i feel like
uh i treat my relationships now very
differently than i did
in the past before losing my brother i
really um
treasure
uh all of my relationships with you know
especially with my parents and my
friends and i just
i mean
life is
very precious
and it could end
at any time
so i just i feel like i have
a lot more love
now in me
that's great
liz thank you so much for sharing your
story thank you sorry about your brother
thank you
thank you
you